en un vídeo anterior vimos que un cable
recto que lleva una corriente eléctrica
produce un campo magnético a su
alrededor en círculos concéntricos en
este vídeo vamos a explorar cómo luce el
campo magnético en una bobina un cable
que forma un bucle y por el que fluye
una corriente eléctrica y les adelanto
que quizás ya estén familiarizados con
estos patrones de campo para ver el
patrón del campo eléctrico
experimentalmente todo lo que tenemos
que hacer es poner algunas ralladuras de
hierro alrededor del cable y es lo que
haremos primero en este vídeo tenemos
cables de cobre formando un círculo y
noten que estos atraviesan un panel de
vidrio dentro de este panel de vidrio
hay ralladuras de hierro de manera que
cuando hacemos que pase una corriente
eléctrica a través de estos cables pasa
por la bobina y va a generar un campo
magnético por lo que las ralladuras de
hierro se van a reacomodar aquí lo
tenemos ya hicimos la conexión y cuando
lo encendemos cerramos el circuito
comienza a pasar corriente y aquí está
vemos cómo se forma el patrón del campo
magnético
hermoso vean lo podemos ver que cerca
del cable el campo está en círculos pero
conforme nos alejamos de los cables y
nos acercamos al centro vemos que los
círculos tienden a ser más grandes
tienen curvas más grandes como lo pueden
ver aquí también tienden a ser más
planas y si vamos al centro de la bobina
vemos que el campo está bastante recto
ahora vamos a tratar de averiguar por
qué se ve así el campo magnético y
veremos que esta es una línea de campo
bastante conocida ya la hemos visto
antes aquí tenemos un anillo de cobre es
un círculo pero lo vemos de lado como en
el caso de la bobina de este vídeo por
lo que lo vemos ovalado y digamos que
hacemos pasar una corriente por él en
esta dirección particular se mueve hacia
el fondo luego por atrás sale del fondo
y de regreso al frente así sucesivamente
justo como éste va hacia la pantalla por
detrás sale y pasa de nuevo por enfrente
haciendo círculos como podemos conocer
cuál es la dirección del campo
alrededor de todo este anillo vimos en
un vídeo anterior que si tenemos un
cable recto podemos usar la regla de la
mano derecha donde básicamente usamos la
mano derecha para sujetar el conductor
de manera que el pulgar está en la
dirección de la corriente y los cuatro
dedos indican la dirección del campo
magnético que está alrededor del cable
recto si quieren saber más al respecto
hemos hablado con más detalles sobre
esto en vídeos anteriores siéntanse
libres de regresar a ver esos vídeos
pero aquí no tenemos un cable recto
tenemos un círculo que hacemos ahora
como usamos la regla de la mano derecha
en este caso bueno todo lo que tenemos
que hacer es sostener cada sección de
este cable de forma separada y calcular
cuál es la dirección del campo magnético
en cada sección veamos un ejemplo
imaginemos que queremos saber cómo es el
campo magnético en esta sección y elijo
esta sección porque es más fácil de
dibujar el campo magnético en este punto
como verán en un momento
a ver cómo luce el campo magnético en
este punto como lo hacemos pues con mi
mano derecha sujeto esta sección de
manera que mi pulgar apunte en la
dirección de la corriente pero cuál es
la dirección de la corriente en este
punto bueno ya que la corriente aquí se
mueve a la derecha entra a la pantalla
en este punto por lo que mi pulgar debe
apuntar hacia la pantalla
veamos cómo luce si sujeto a esta parte
se verá así no pueden ver mi pulgar
porque mi pulgar apunta hacia la
pantalla y mis cuatro dedos indican la
dirección del campo magnético alrededor
de esta sección noten que estos dedos
van en sentido horario por lo que sé que
en esta sección el campo magnético va en
sentido horario de forma similar ahora
vamos a considerar esta sección de nuevo
elijo esta sección porque va a ser más
fácil de dibujar su campo magnético aquí
vemos que la corriente sale de la
pantalla sale y luego va hacia la
derecha si sujetamos esta sección del
cable puede
imaginar cómo se va a ver pues en este
caso mi mano derecha recuerden que
solamente debemos usar la mano derecha
estará de forma que el pulgar apunta
hacia afuera de la pantalla si lo sujeto
con mi mano derecha se verá así ahora
vemos los cuatro dedos que rodean el
cable que van en sentido antihorario por
lo que sabemos que el campo magnético en
esta sección tiene sentido antihorario
esto explica los campos circulares de
aquí ahora para saber cómo es el campo
magnético en todo el anillo no tenemos
que estar repitiendo esto una y otra vez
hay una forma de averiguar cómo podría
verse el campo magnético es así como lo
haremos si vemos esta parte nos dice que
el campo por adentro del anillo apunta
hacia arriba y por fuera del anillo
apunta hacia abajo lo mismo ocurre de
este lado el campo magnético por dentro
del bucle la bobina
hacia arriba y por fuera del bucle el
campo magnético va hacia abajo de hecho
sin importar cual sección del cable
sujetemos el campo eléctrico por dentro
va a ir hacia arriba y por afuera irá
hacia abajo para convencerlos permítanme
mostrar otras dos secciones que
sujetamos aquí están usamos la misma
regla de la mano derecha donde el pulgar
apunta en la dirección de la corriente y
podemos ver claramente que los cuatro
dedos nos dicen que por dentro el campo
va hacia arriba y que por afuera el
campo va hacia abajo por dentro va hacia
arriba y por afuera va hacia abajo con
esto sabemos que en todo el cable el
campo magnético por dentro va a ir hacia
arriba y por fuera va a ir hacia abajo y
que tiene que haber círculos cercanos
porque todas las líneas de campos se
mueven de esta forma pueden verlo ahora
se lo imaginan si queremos dibujar el
campo completo quitamos estas manos para
poder ver bien las líneas del campo
magnético es así cómo lucen todas las
el campo magnético vean que todas van
hacia arriba cuando pasan por dentro de
la bobina y tienden a ir hacia abajo
cuando están por fuera de ella esto es
exactamente lo que tenemos en el
experimento lo último que les quiero
preguntar es si esta forma les parece
familiar y para eso permítanme alejar la
imagen un poco más
muy bien aquí la tenemos admiren el
hermoso patrón del campo a qué se parece
esto bueno pues el campo luce muy
similar al campo creado por un pequeño
imán hemos visto cómo luce el campo
magnético de un imán se ve más o menos
así vean ambos patrones de campos no
lucen muy similares aquí la línea del
campo comienza aquí y continúa dando la
vuelta de esta forma aquí las líneas de
campo también comienzan de este lugar y
dan la vuelta de la misma manera las
diferencias que pueden notar es que el
campo está un poco más aplanado y acá el
campo es más redondo pero si este imán
fuera mucho más pequeño noten que
tendríamos un patrón de campo muy
parecido a este otro esto significa que
una bobina que lleva una corriente se
parece a un pequeño imán y ahora podemos
decir que este lado representa el polo
norte del imán y este otro lado es el
polo sur del imán los polos realmente no
están aquí pero si imaginamos esto como
un pequeño imán
podemos tratarlo de esta forma esto es
genial porque ahora aprendimos cómo
crear nuestros propios imanes
artificiales así que en este vídeo
aprendimos cómo encontrar el campo
magnético alrededor de una bobina un
bucle por el que pasa una corriente
usando la misma regla de la mano derecha
y después vimos que un bucle que lleva
una corriente va a ser equivalente a un
pequeño imán